[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous pour regarder
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le deal du siècle
une initiative plus qu'ambitieuse du
président américain censé régler le
conflit israélo-palestinien or pour être
mises en oeuvre elles devront encore
être acceptée par les palestiniens aient
surmonté le scepticisme de la communauté
internationale mission impossible
c'est ce que nous allons voir
aujourd'hui karl annonce de ce deal ne
laisse personne indifférent le 28
janvier 2020 donald trump dévoile son
plan
une initiative qu'il qualifie de
consensus fidèle au conflit
israélo-palestinien à ses côtés le
premier ministre israélien benjamin
netanyahu le remercier et l'appel
meilleur ami d'israël cependant l'autre
partie impliquée dans le deal l'autorité
palestinienne refuse catégoriquement
ne serait-ce que de l'examiner à peine
publié le deal a suscité de vives
réactions dans le monde l'union
européenne et la russie émettent des
doutes quant à la viabilité de cet
accord plus encore l'iran et la turquie
dénonce une violation flagrante du droit
international de son côté les ligue
arabe condamne elle aussi le projet
américain
mais le monde arabe dans son ensemble
paraît diviser l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis l'egypte regarde
d'un oeil favorable le deal de trempe
sont pour autant abandonner
officiellement la cause palestinienne la
jordanie quand elle rejette fermement ce
plan
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur le partage des
territoires entre l'autorité
palestinienne et israël
c'est le bit selon la définition de
l'onu les territoires palestiniens
comprennent deux zones séparées l'une de
l'autre par israël la cisjordanie est la
bande de gaza ces deux territoires forme
l'état de palestine qui n'est reconnu
que par 136 états sur les 193 états
membres de l'onu
théoriquement c'était à est dirigée par
l'autorité palestinienne dont la
capitale et jérusalem est
dans les faits la situation est bien
différente la bande de gaza est
actuellement contrôlé par le mouvement
radical hamas l'autorité palestinienne
exerce pleinement son pouvoir que sur 19
pour cent de la rive ouest du jourdain
22% de ce territoire est sous le
contrôle administratif palestiniens mais
sa sécurité est entre les mains d'israël
le reste de la cisjordanie est
entièrement administrée par israël la
ville de jérusalem elle aussi se trouve
sous le contrôle de l'état hébreu qui là
proclame en 1980 sa capitale unie et
indivisible
depuis 1948 le conflit israélo
palestinien est suivi de très près par
le nu sa position toute solution doit
être conforme au droit international et
satisfaire à deux conditions
la première permettre la création de
deux états arabes et juives coexistant
pacifiquement la deuxième être basé sur
les frontières d'avant 1967 à l'époque
israël n'occupe eini la cisjordanie et
la bande de gaza ni jérusalem est après
un suspense de plus de 3 ans donald
trump dévoile fin janvier son plan de
paix très attendu pour le moyen-orient
son objectif paraît comme plus
qu'optimiste il veut mettre fin au
conflit israélo-palestinien qui dure
depuis plus d'un demi siècle pour cela
l'accord prévoit la création de l'état
de palestine qui sera elle s'engagerait
à reconnaître cependant les palestiniens
devraient faire un certain nombre de
concessions à israël accepter l'annexion
de la vallée du jourdain se désarmer
complètement ou encore reconnaître
jérusalem comme capitale indivisible
israélienne les palestiniens quant à eux
auraient leur propre capital dans la
banlieue de jérusalem est au delà du mur
de sécurité en cas de signature de
l'accord les américains promettent des
investissements
colossaux dans l'économie de la
palestine un compromis que le premier
ministre israélien considère comme la
solution idéale
l'autorité palestinienne elle ne veut
même pas en entendre parler et crié à la
violation flagrante du droit
international
une position partagée également par
l'iran et la turquie qui se place en
chef de file dans la défense des
intérêts des palestiniens la jordanie
aussi rejette fermement le deal le monde
arabe lui semble être divisée l'arabie
saoudite les émirats arabes unis
l'egypte salue le plan de trump et le
considère digne d'être examinées sans
pour autant abandonner complètement la
cause palestinienne pourquoi ces
divergences de positions comment les
poids lourds géopolitique réagissent à
la corde 30
enfin quel impact pour at il à voir sur
les élections législatives israéliennes
prévues pour mars 2020 pour répondre à
ces questions nous rejoignons gérard
chaliand écrivain et spécialiste des
relations internationales
messieurs chaliand bonjour bonjour tout
d'abord pensez vous que le deal du
siècle a des chances d'être mises en
oeuvre
d'abord ce pas un deal c'est un diktat
c'est à dire que au fond il n'y a pas eu
de concertation pour faire une
proposition qui serait discutable de
part et d'autre donc c'est en quelque
sorte comme je vis un diktat
est ce que est ce que ça va être mis en
pratique
monsieur 30 à faire ce qu'il faut pour
ça mais apparemment pour l'instant les
réactions de l'autre côté sont négatives
c'est à dire que il ya blocage donc on
peut on peut vraiment rien dire sur
l'avenir sinon qu il y aura de très
grosses difficultés pour faire passer ce
fameux deal donc si les chances de ses
réalisations sont inexistantes
quel est son but selon vous d'abord ça
renforce monsieur natanyahou surya de la
politique quand même local là dedans
dans le différend entre
monsieur gander et puis monsieur
natanyahou sont les grosso modo à 50/50
bon monsieur trump de façon très nette à
puis l'option un monsieur natanyahou
voir en politique qui israël voit cela
maintenant en politique israélo
palestiniennes bon on reste tout de même
dans quelque chose de très obscur ce qui
est offert sur le plan territorial c'est
zéro ce qui est offert du point de vue
possibilités de transformation
écologique bon il ya une tentative en
quelque sorte d'acheter l'adversaire par
les propositions économiques qui ne sont
pas inintéressantes
enfin on ne sait pas du tout où ça va
mener compte tenu de l'opposition d'une
partie des pays arabes
malgré malgré qu'il ya quand même
quelques alliés du côté de monsieur
trompe
par ailleurs le deal a été annoncée 33
jours avant les élections en israël
selon avigdor lieberman chef du parti
israël beitenou ce plan et rien d'autre
qu'un coup médiatique vous d'accord avec
lui il si c'en est un à qui ils
profitent rue c'est un coup médiatique
aussi est à mon avis ça profite
essentiellement à monsieur benjamin
natanyahu seulement un coup un donc un
coup médiatique est il bien réalisé est
ce que vous vous vous pensez que les
positions de netanyahou depuis
l'annnonce de ce coup médiatique ont été
renforcées vraiment on peut pas dire ça
on peut pas dire que ça a été décisif
mais ça peut l'avoir aidé parce que en
réalité la différence en matière de voix
est tellement faible qu'un petit coup de
pouce et ça peut changer la donne donc
c'est de toute façon un avantage pour
monsieur benjamin natanyahu
indiscutablement merci beaucoup monsieur
chaliand nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons en fin d'émission
pour plus de détails sur la question le
28 janvier 2020 le président américain
présente enfin son plan de paix comme le
deal du siècle pour le moyen-orient au
côté du premier ministre israélien
benjamin netanyahu long de plus de 180
pages l'accord prévoit la coexistence de
deux états qui se reconnaîtrait
mutuellement israël et le futur état de
palestine
ce dernier serait dirigée par les
représentants élus par le peuple
palestinien et comprendrait la bande de
gaza et la majeure partie de la
cisjordanie la vallée du jourdain ainsi
que toutes les colonies israéliennes
créé depuis 1967 serait rattachée à
israël en retour les américains
proposent aux palestiniens deux poches
israélienne dans le désert du negev avec
une route reliant ces territoires avec
la bande de gaza celle ci sera en plus
connectés au reste du territoire
palestinien via une liaison en train à
grande vitesse
quant au statut de jérusalem le plan de
trains évite toute ambiguïté la ville
serait la capitale unie et indivisible
d'israël les palestiniens auraient aussi
la leur dans la banlieue de jérusalem
est en dehors du mur de sécurité
cependant les choses ne sont pas si
simple car le nouvel état de palestine
n'aurait qu'une souveraineté très
limitée selon le plan la sécurité du
futur état sera assurée par israël qui
aurait le droit d'intervenir
militairement sur les territoires
palestiniens soit pour s'assurer du
respect des accords de désarmement soit
pour prévenir les menaces à sa sécurité
la palestine elles seraient totalement
démilitarisées le hamas le aussi devrait
déposer ses armes
l'autre point clé de l'accord est la
solution proposée à la crise des
réfugiés palestiniens en cours depuis la
création de l'état juif en 1948 le
document stipule qu'il n'y aura pas de
droit au retour ou à l'intégration des
réfugiés palestiniens dans l'état
d'israël
ces derniers devront choisir l'une des
trois options l'absorption en l'état
palestinien
l'intégration dans les pays d'accueil
actuelles ou enfin l'installation l'un
des pays membres de l'organisation de la
coopération islamique
côté palestinien les sacrifices seraient
donc nombreux cependant en cas de
signature de l'accord la palestine
recevrez une manne financière promise
par le volet économique du deal
baptisé de la paix à la prospérité le
document est présenté en juin 2019 par
le gendre est conseillé de donald trump
jared kushner selon ses conditions d
investissements internationaux à la
hauteur de 50 milliards de dollars
seraient injectés dans la région dont 27
milliards de dollars dans l'économie
palestinienne développement enseignement
santé transports infrastructures
tourisme la transformation en profondeur
est promise dans toutes les sphères de
vie selon les études américaines la
pauvreté en palestine serait divisé par
deux alors que son pib doublerait les
deux volets du deal sont accueillis à
bras ouverts par israël le président
américain quant à lui ne perd pas
l'occasion de vanter son accord de paix
une réussite historique
selon lui toutes les administrations
précédentes depuis celle du président
lyndon johnson ont essayé et échoué
amèrement mais je n'ai pas été élu pour
faire de petites choses ou pour éviter
les gros problèmes
pourtant un problème de taille se dresse
devant le président américain c'est la
réaction de la palestine qui n'a même
pas été invité à la table de
négociations l'accord du siècle ne
passera pas et notre peuple où l'on
verra dans les poubelles de l'histoire
nous disons non non non à la sphère du
siècle
très vite les palestiniens passent des
paroles aux actes le lendemain de
l'annoncé de l'accord l'ambassadeur
palestinien auprès de l'onu se dit prêt
à se mettre au conseil de sécurité une
résolution condamnant le plan de train à
l'onu pourtant les discussions autour du
deal vont bon train sans réfuter
directement l'accord le secrétaire
général de l'organisation au fait valoir
que l'initiative de donald trump ne
correspond pas tout à fait à sa vision
du règlement du conflit
l'onu reste déterminée à aider les
palestiniens et les israéliens à
résoudre le conflit en se basant sur les
résolutions des nations unies et à
réaliser la vision de deux états israël
et palestine vivant côte à côte dans la
paix et la sécurité à l'intérieur de
frontières reconnues sur la base des
lignes antérieures à 1967
cette position est également partagée
par l'union européenne qui s'inquiète
des conséquences imprévisibles de
l'application de l'accord conformément
au droit international et aux
résolutions pertinentes du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies l'union
européenne ne reconnaît pas la
souveraineté d'israël sur les
territoires occupés depuis 1967
les mesures en vue de l'annexion si
elles sont mises en oeuvre ne pourrait
pas passer sans être contestées une
réaction qui met en colère les autorités
israéliennes celle ci ne tarde pas à
riposter
le fait que le haut représentant de l'ua
josep borrell ait choisi d'utiliser un
langage menaces envers israël si peu de
temps après avoir pris ses fonctions et
seulement quelques heures après ces
réunions en iran est regrettable est
pour le moins étrange
en quête de soutiens le premier ministre
isralien se rend alors à moscou c'est sa
première visite à l'étranger depuis
l'annoncé de l'accord à washington
l'objectif discuter avec le chef de
l'état russe du plan proposé par donald
trump pourtant les négociations se
déroulent à huis clos
après la rencontre il devient évident
que les deux dirigeants ne sont pas
arrivés à rapprocher leurs positions
on peut voir à l'oeil nu que certaines
dispositions de ce plan ne correspondent
pas entièrement aux dispositions des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité
nous voyons la réaction des palestiniens
nous voyons la réaction d'un certain
nombre d'états arabes
ceci bien sûr amène à réfléchir à sa
viabilité
quelle est donc la réaction des états
arabes
comment le plan de tram peut-il modifier
l'échiquier politique régional
comment ce deal peut-il influencer la
campagne électorale en israël la réponse
après la pause
[Musique]
des rencontres au plus haut niveau des
débats et des négociations il aura fallu
attendre près de trois ans pour
apprendre la teneur de ce deal du siècle
du président américain
pourtant at il des chances d'instaurer
la paix car depuis les années 90 aucune
tentative n'a été couronnée de succès en
1991 en plein pendant la première
intifada la conférence de madrid a lieu
c'est la première tentative
internationale dans le processus de paix
au proche orient
soutenu par les américains et l'union
soviétique elle réunit pour la première
fois les israéliens les palestiniens et
les pays arabes à la table des
négociations
même si cette conférence ne débouche pas
sur des actions concrètes
elle lance une série de négociations
secrètes qui débouche en 1993 un accord
historique
le 13 septembre 1993 le premier ministre
israélien itzhak rabin et le chef de
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine olp yasser arafat se
réunissent à washington en présence du
président américain bill clinton lors de
cette rencontre historique il signe les
accords d'oslo
ceux ci prévoient une reconnaissance
mutuelle entre israël et l'olp et le
retrait des troupes israéliennes de la
bande de gaza et de la ville de jéricho
en cisjordanie et une autonomie de la
palestine au bout de cinq ans de plus
cet accord met officiellement fin à la
première intifada en 1995 l'accord oslo
2 viendra s'y ajouter
il porte sur l'extension de l'autonomie
palestinienne et le retrait des troupes
israéliennes des civils de la
cisjordanie
bethleem jénine quelques il ya naplouse
ramallah et tulkarem
cependant depuis l'assassinât d'itzhak
rabin en 1995 par un extrémiste juif et
l'arrivée au pouvoir de benjamin
netanyahu opposants aux accords d'oslo
le processus de paix patine
certes les accords ont apporté une
reconnaissance mutuelle mais la question
sur le partage et territoires la
délimitation des frontières et la
création d'un état palestinien
reste en suspens en 1998 les états unis
tentent de relancer les négociations
entre les deux opposants yasser arafat
et benjamin netanyahu si les accords de
huy planter chez le 23 octobre 1998
selon ces accords les israéliens
acceptent de retirer leurs troupes une
partie de la cisjordanie qui passe alors
sous contrôle palestinien
de leur côté les palestiniens s'engagent
à lutter contre le terrorisme et à
supprimer les articles de leur charte
nationale qui appelle à la destruction
de l'état d'israël
pourtant faute de volonté politique ces
accords ne sont pas véritablement
appliquée et le retrait des troupes
israéliennes n'est que partielle et
violences sur le terrain persiste en
juillet 2000 les états unis s'opposent à
nouveau co médiateur au sommet de camp
david
mais les négociations aboutissent à un
énième échec le début de la deuxième
intifada en septembre 2000 marquent un
gel des négociations entre les deux
camps trois ans après l'échec américain
le quarté pour le moyen-orient composé
de la russie des états unis de l'union
européenne et de l'onu propose une
feuille de route
elle prévoit la création d'un état
palestinien d'ici 2005 et le gel de la
colonisation israël
elle sera approuvée par les deux camps
mais aucun ne respecte ses obligations
en novembre 2007 israël et l'autorité
palestinienne se retrouve à nouveau aux
états unis lors du processus d'annapolis
afin de négocier un accord d'ici 2008
cependant les espoirs sont plombées
suite à la poursuite de la colonisation
israélienne et l'offensive israélienne
sur gaza fin 2008
dès lors alors que les violences contre
la bande de gaza se poursuit le
processus de normalisation des relations
israélo-palestiniennes patine il faudra
attendre 2017 et la réunion de plus de
70 pays à la conférence de paris
consacrée au conflit israélo palestinien
pourtant ni l'état hébreu ni l'autorité
palestinienne ni ont assisté à l'issue
de cette conférence les participants
préconisent la solution à deux états
afin de résoudre le conflit israélo
palestinien
néanmoins ils avertissent qu'ils ne
reconnaîtront pas d'actions unilatérales
et ne feront pas d'impasse sur la
question des réfugiés et sur le sort de
jérusalem
rompant avec plusieurs principes des
accords précédents le plan de donald
trump n'a pas reçu un accueil très
chaleureux dans le monde islamique sans
surprise c'est l'iran qui s'y opposent
le plus farouchement selon tehran le
deal favorise tellement son vieil
adversaire régional qu'il mérite le nom
de trahison du siècle le menteur
hypocrite président américain et le
régime sionistes ont préparé un
cauchemar pour les pays islamiques et
ont présenté un plan qui n'est qu'un
accord commercial et qui vise en réalité
à diviser les pays islamiques
des mots forts de la part d'un pays dont
les relations avec washington sont déjà
on ne peut plus tendue la turquie se
rangent d'ailleurs du même côté sur fond
de frictions avec les américains le
président turc erdogan profite de
l'occasion pour se poser en chef de file
régional et affiche une opposition
féroce au projet américain
la position officielle du reste du monde
islamique est similaire
la ligue arabe rejettent le plan israélo
américain puisqu'il ne respecte pas le
minimum des aspirations et des droits
légitimes du peuple palestinien et
contredit les termes de références du
processus de paix selon le secrétariat
général de la ligue il s'agit d'une
position obligatoire pour tous les
membres pourtant la réalité est plus
nuancée
au lieu de présenter un front uni les
pays arabes sont en effet divisés
certains affichent même un soutien
prudent à l'initiative de donald trump
le signe le plus marquant de ce soutien
trois pays du golfe persique ont envoyé
des ambassadeurs à washington pour
assister à l'annoncé solennelle du plan
de trump ce sont les émirats arabes unis
le bahreïn et le man 3 pics
le dirigeant américain a personnellement
remercier pour leur soutien
washington maintient d'ailleurs des
relations très proches avec ces états il
possède par exemple des bases militaires
aux émirats et au bahreïn pourtant son
allié le plus proche dans la région
l'arabie saoudite et était absent de la
cérémonie à washington
mais selon le quotidien hébreu maariv
son soutien ne devrait pas tarder à se
matérialiser avec les autres états du
golfe ryad aurait promis de financer lé
enveloppe de 50 milliards de dollars
prévus par le deal du siècle pour
développer la région
côté diplomatie le royaume saoudien
assure ne pas abandonner la cause
palestinienne mais ne manque pas non
plus d'exprimer son appui au plan
américain
le royaume réitère son soutien tous les
efforts visant à parvenir à un règlement
juste et complet de la question
palestinienne le royaume apprécié les
efforts de l'administration du président
trump en vue d'élaborer un plan
exhaustif de paix une déclaration
reprise quasiment mot pour mot par la
diplomatie égyptienne -l'un des deux
états arabes ayant des relations
officielles avec israël
néanmoins si le reste du monde arabe n'a
pas de liens diplomatiques officielles
avec tel-aviv
cela ne veut pas pour autant dire qu'il
n'ya aucun contact
au contraire les relations
arabo-israéliennes ne cesse de se
réchauffer ces dernières années en
juillet 2019 le chef de la diplomatie
israélienne visite la conférence sur le
climat de l'onu à abou dhabi plus encore
pendant le déplacement il rencontre en
tête à tête en haut responsable émirati
un an avant le premier ministre
israélien benjamin netanyahu avait
visité oman et rencontrer le sultan du
royaume
une première depuis plus de 20 ans à
bahreïn le gouvernement déclare en 2019
qui souhaiteraient avoir des relations
pacifiques avec israël quant à l'arabie
saoudite des signes de rapprochement
sont visibles depuis 2018 le prince
mohammed bin salman avait alors reconnu
le droit des israéliens à leur propre
état et jusqu'avant l'annnonce du deal
du siècle tel aviv venait d'autoriser
ses citoyens à voyager dans le royaume
saoudien
tout cela pour faire face à une menace
commune en octobre 2019 la diplomatie
israélienne révèle qu'elle travaille sur
un pacte de non-agression avec plusieurs
états arabes pour lutter ensemble contre
l'iran il ya pourtant
un maillon faible dans cette tendance de
détente arabo israélienne la jordanie
voisine israël lié avec lui par des
liens diplomatiques officielles malgré
des relations assez proche avec tel-aviv
elle est particulièrement alarmés par la
promesse de netanyahu d' annexé
unilatéralement la vallée du jourdain
l'annexion par israël de la vallée du
jourdain et du nord de la mer morte
réduire à néant les fondations du
processus de paix quoi qu'il en soit ce
plan fortement médiatisée avait été
annoncée par netanyahou peu avant les
élections législatives
plusieurs titres locaux et ses
adversaires politiques l'avaient alors
baptisé de coude comme pour attirer des
voix
le dévoilement officiel de son contenu à
un mois de nouvelles élections
israéliennes témoigne encore dans le
timing favorable pour netanyahou adopté
un plan si détaillé compliqué 33 jours
avant les élections ne peut être rien
d'autre qu'un coup médiatique
en effet depuis un an l'avenir politique
de benjamin netanyahu est plus
qu'incertain en avril 2019 même s'il a
techniquement gagner les élections à la
knesset il ne réussit pas à former la
coalition dirigeante des élections
anticipées de septembre 2019 ne l'êtes
pas non plus à former une majorité
pire le parti likoud de netanyahou est
battu par son concurrent le bleu blanc
de benny gantz
pendant toute cette période benjamin
netanyahu dirigé le gouvernement par
intérim et se montre fragilisées de
nouvelles élections législatives
anticipées qui doivent mettre fin à
l'incertitude sont fixé au 2 mars le
plan trump pour le moyen orient élaborée
en proche collaboration avec son
gouvernement pourrait apparaître comme
une victoire diplomatique pour le leader
du likoud mais le contexte électoral est
donc d'autant plus difficile pour
netanyahou qu'il fait désormais l'objet
d'une enquête pénale
inculpé pour corruption dans trois
affaires distinctes il est le premier
chef du gouvernement israélien en
exercice juge
et pour de tels délits entre enquêtes
pénales et manquent d'assise électorale
le plan de donald trump arrive à point
nommé
il est d'ailleurs présentée le même jour
que l'annoncé de l'inculpation de
benjamin netanyahu
alors si le deal du siècle n'apporte pas
la paix dans ce conflit vieux de plus de
70 ans
réussira-t-il au moins à sauver l'avenir
politique du premier ministre israélien
dans un contexte de rapprochement
arabo-israélien la position
intransigeante de la part des
palestiniens peut-elle se retourner
contre eux pour mieux comprendre si la
vision de paix de donald trump et
réaliste nous revenons vers gérard
chaliand écrivain et spécialiste des
relations internationales
monsieur chaliand l'union européenne la
russie ou encore antonio gutiérrez sont
plus que sceptiques sur la viabilité du
deal pensez vous que netanyahou ou trump
réussiront quand même alors faire
changer d'avis non je ne pense pas je
pense pas mais enfin se lit dans cette
histoire l'europe ne pèse pas grand
chose pour la bonne raison que nous
n'avons pas une voie politique commune
on l'a déjà vu à plusieurs reprises
permets de vous rappeler par exemple que
il ya quelques temps déjà que monsieur
trump avait dit aux européens vous avez
180 jours pour décider si vous voulez
commercer avec téhéran ou continuer de
commercer avec washington
nous avons dit non non non non
et puis finalement on a dit oui parce
que finalement on était totalement
divisée donc le poids de l'europe la
danse est un poids strictement moral
mais notre capacité de peser et à peu
près nulles
donc les chances de monsieur trempe ne
sont pas extraordinaires non plus parce
que ce qu'il offre est très difficile à
accepter mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
proposer d'autres en fassent des des
solutions je dirais non réalisable est
ce que les palestiniens ont
véritablement la force nécessaire pour
imposer un point de vue qui soit
radicalement différent ce qu'ils sont
capables par exemple d'organiser une
grève générale pour pour signifier
qu'ils sont absolument opposés à ce deal
comme on dit voilà des choses qui
n'apparaissent pas du tout il est
surprenant que le monde à are able
semblent divisés sur cette question les
ambassadeurs émirati bahrénien ou oman
et était présent lors de l'annoncé du
deal à washington et ryad aurait même
promis de financer les financières
prévues par l'accord les pays arabes
alliés aux états unis tourne-t-il le dos
palestiniens pensez vous moi je pense
qu'ils pensent à leurs intérêts c'est à
dire que il faut franchement dire que le
ya beau temps que le monde arabe
n'estime plus que la question
palestinienne est absolument centrale
dans leurs relations internationales
bons que ceux qui sont accrochés au
wagon américains comme ceux du golfe que
vous êtes mentionné bas ils vont jouer
la carte américaine autant que faire se
peut parce que leurs intérêts se trouve
là et que les intérêts des palestiniens
ma foi c'est totalement secondaire pour
eux donc le front du refus en quelque
sorte ça va être ce qu'ils ne sont pas
les alliés de des états unis
sur au sens où ils ne sont pas
directement dépendants de l'économie
américain de leurs relations avec les
etats-unis 2-2 des intérêts de
washington
la fission la halle comment dirais-je la
scission est effective
elle s'exprime cette fois de façon
ouverte alors que d'une façon générale
on disait bon les érables pense que la
position des arabes est la suivante
merci beaucoup gérard chaliand je
rappelle vous et écrivain spécialiste
des relations internationales merci
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage cette
partie là n'est pas encore terminée la
semaine prochaine une nouvelle partie
vous attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]